[Music]
hi
i'm dakota i am fully out of shape since
the start of quarantine
and before i've been getting very little
exercise
because i'm a human piece of garbage so
starting today i am going to change that
for the next 30 days i'm going to be
doing
100 burpees a day thankfully i don't
have to do this alone i'm going to be
joined by my friend jasmine
who has agreed to do this along with me
thank you so much jasmine
yeah i don't know why i'm doing this i
do kind of regret it
[Music]
i am overall a very athletic person but
lately in quarantine i've just been
a middle-aged korean woman standing in
front of her tv doing aerobics while
watching korean dramas
do i like burpees no my knees don't like
it my ankles don't like it my wrists
don't like it but i want to look
cute wow i never thought i'd be taking
my clothes off in a video at least not
this kind of video so here
is my body i'm definitely in a physical
condition
it's not so bad but it can get better
it's day one
i change into my workout clothes and
we're gonna just see how many burpees i
can do
a burpee is a combination of a jump a
squat a plank and a push-up so it really
targets a lot of your body
[Music]
why did i agree to this does my butt
look better yet
i'm pretty excited to do this next out
of 100 burpees
i don't know why i said that i'm not
that excited to do that
it is the morning of day three my abs
hurt
[Music]
i asked dakota if we get recovery days
for this challenge
and he laughs i think that's a no
i really don't want to do the burpees
today i actually purposely stayed in bed
longer
just so i could delay the day
week one is officially over
learned that mindset was of the utmost
importance when starting your burpees
hi it's week two and i've gained four
pounds these burpees make me so hungry
[Music]
i have not been doing the push-ups with
the burpees because
i don't have a lot of arm strength so
starting today i'm gonna start
trying to incorporate push-ups one thing
i've noticed is that i'm also sort of
now thinking a little bit more about the
rest of my day while i'm doing this
exercise i think it's reminding me that
like yeah my health
is important and that sure doing burpees
is healthy but it's only one aspect of
like a healthy lifestyle
[Music]
i really didn't want to do them today so
i came to terms with skipping today
and then george my boyfriend was like no
i'll do it with you you don't need to
skip
anyway he did it with me and now he's
dying on the floor so
so jasmine and i have a call right now
with a personal trainer who's going to
watch us do a burpee
and give us comments on our form and
then teach us how to properly do
a burpee hello everyone my name is kiana
vestudo i
am an ace certified personal trainer
based in los angeles california
today i'm going to show you how to do a
burpee
essentially burpee is a full body
movement it works your lower body it
works your upper body it works your core
it gets your cardiovascular system
working when done properly and with
proper form it is a super
super effective movement should we show
you how we've been doing our burpees and
then you can like tell us what we're
doing wrong
that's actually really good dakota your
feet were like almost
almost close together read those feet a
little bit wider kind of like shoulder
width apart squat down almost place
those hands right inside of those
those feet and then you're gonna jump
out from there
no major corrections for you though
jasmine try to shift those weights in
your heels trying not to
jump those feet in on those toes so
shifting those weights in those heels
and lifting that chest jumping to the
top so go crush these burpees i believe
in you
i've thought long and hard about it i've
decided i'm not doing my burpees today i
love
myself happy birthday to me goodbye
so i failed today and i only did 50
burpees
tomorrow i'm going to do all of them i'm
not going to fail
and i'm not going to fail again for the
rest of the month
it's week three after yesterday i
got really bad back pain and i think
just taking it easy today with all half
push-ups will set me up better for the
rest of the week
[Music]
[Music]
my back really won't stop hurting and
i'm pretty sure i'm doing something
wrong
i think i need to take today off
[Music]
so i feel like i've sort of reached a
point of plateau i feel like i sort of
stopped improving and now things seem to
just be getting harder
yesterday was a sad day because i
skipped
my burpees again i couldn't even sit
myself up to get out of bed
today the back pain has not completely
dissipated
but it does feel a lot better
i've enlisted my mother to try and do
some burpees with me today
jump squat
i just woke up my back is killing me
i have to skip today's burpees i'm so
mad because
it's not every day where you enter a
workout challenge and you're
mentally in and physically in and this
is like one of the very few times where
i felt like i was both
super in
so i'm buying this back stretcher i just
really want to be able to do some
more burpees before this challenge ends
[Music]
i'm gonna try this out
[Music]
my back feels a lot better today i think
i'm gonna try doing push-ups on the wall
i know today's burpees weren't exactly
burpees and they were
really severe modifications but honestly
getting into
some sort of exercise routine again
feels much better than doing nothing
[Music]
so this is it today is finally my last
day
of doing burpees i cannot believe that
i've done close to
3 000 of these in the last month this is
my last murphy for the [ __ ] for the
month
oh it's gonna be the best murphy i've
ever done
[Music]
when i first said i would do this
challenge i was really
hopeful and determined and optimistic i
just wanted it to be
a happy story i can't control what
happened
during this journey and the only thing
i'm disappointed about is the
satisfaction of the before and after
right so when i first started all of
this i had people from flat earth groups
reaching out to me asking if they could
use my ass as their logo
i have some sort of curve on my butt
which is nice i don't think i'm going to
continue doing 100 burpees a day because
i don't think that is like humanly
possible anymore so maybe instead i'll
do my usual thing and implement burpees
with correct form
slowly i cannot believe i'm finally done
i don't feel like i look particularly
different but i definitely feel a little
bit different i feel a lot stronger my
roommate and i moved over the weekend
up and down five flights of stairs lots
of furniture boxes
and he's been complaining about soreness
and his legs and i haven't noticed any
of that soreness i think because of this
overall that i
am definitely going to continue putting
a little bit more exercise and thought
into my lifestyle choices
so i would call this a success
[Music]
you